hallo Christoph
ich höre dich sehr gut und ziehe meinen
Hut erstmal hier
hallo Christian
sieht sehr in Sachsen lassen
das Brusthaar oder was meinst das Brust
nee das hatte ich ja immer schon das war
auch als Lena schon mein Markenzeichen
und ich habe es mir nicht nehmen lass
uns auch weiter zu tragen jetzt in
dieses Flug wie geht's dir nein nein
Quatsch Quatsch Quatsch falsche Frage
wie ist die Lage wie ist die Lage alles
locker und entspannt bis jetzt wir haben
unsere Arbeiten abgeschlossen am neuen
Lied in der Diskothek netzte Video und
äh freuen uns alles sehr bei uns schon
angekündigt dass ihr noch was machen
werdet ähm aber ihr habt euch jetzt Zeit
gelassen habt ihr euch jetzt erstmal
gesammelt oder was habt ihr in der
Zwischenzeit gemacht ja sowas will seine
Zeit brauchen wir waren ja nun
zusammengewürfeltes Projekt eigentlich
durch den Schland Erfolg dann plötzlich
losgeschickt in die große weite Welt
sind dann auf Tour gegangen hatten diese
Wahnsinns Geschichte hinter uns die
ganzen Leute im Rücken und waren dann
plötzlich das Projekt Uwe Lena wir waren
aber weder eine Band
noch ansonsten ein festes Projekt vorher
gewesen sondern einfach nur Freunde die
schon öfter mal zusammen Musik gemacht
hatten Videos gedreht Bilder gemacht und
so weiter und so fort und dann mussten
wir nach der Sache erstmal sehen machen
wir weiter und wenn ja was machen wir
und haben gesagt wir machen weiter aber
wir mussten dann ganz von vorne anfangen
und quasi als Band neu gründen und
Anfang
schreiben dann musste man die auch
aufnehmen ja und gigantische Fotos was
hat denn dieser Erfolg von Standort bei
euch in der jetzt existierenden Band
verändert
ja der hat verändert dass es uns
überhaupt erstmal als Band gibt und dass
wir verstärkt in dieser festen Truppe
jetzt zusammenarbeiten dass wir uns äh
in der Freizeit muss man auch sagen wir
haben nebenbei alle noch andere Dinge zu
tun keiner von uns hat das Studium
abgebrochen jetzt vermehrt auf das
Projekt konzentrieren und ähm ja dass
wir auch viele schöne Dinge zusammen
erlebt haben hattet ihr dann sofort das
selbstver
trauen knüpfen zu können oder habt ihr
auch so selbst Zweifel gehabt
ob das noch mal so gelingt
naja ob das noch mal so gelingt das wird
sich ja erst zeigen dann ist ja nach wie
vor eine Sache der Leute die sagen
müssen mir gefällt das ich möchte das
angucken ich möchte das Lied hören ich
zeig's meinen Freunden weiter rum und
die später das Ding vielleicht dann auch
kaufen werden für uns war ganz klar nach
dem Erfolg von Standort wir möchten
weitermachen wir möchten für uns noch
mal richtig gutes Ding raushauen was uns
gefällt
es mal zusammen und überlegt mein Gott
was war das für ein Jahr was kann doch
alles werden was sagt ihr euch dann
gegenseitig
ja Lena möchten wir immer noch gerne
treffen das ist noch nicht passiert das
ist noch nicht passiert das hat sie noch
nicht ergeben obwohl beide Seiten immer
da mehr von Interesse begründet haben
möchte ich auch jetzt noch mal direkt
sagen Lena wenn du das hörst demnächst
sollten wir doch mal Zeit finden dafür
ja also das muss doch stattfinden Lena
treffen und was kann dann auch alles
passieren ähm
also Stefan wollte uns zu lang Zeit mir
mal auf der Couch haben hat da nicht
ganz geklappt weil im Urlaub war was man
ihm auch gönnen musste nach der Zeit
jetzt ist die WM vorbei wir haben wieder
lieb
ich hätte nichts dagegen damals zu
sitzen dann weiß ich nicht gibt es noch
diverse
Jahresrückblicke ich weiß nicht was da
noch alles kommt das ist locker auf mich
zukommen wenn es nur die Sendung und
studentenradio wird dann ist auch alles
wunderbar aber es ist mir zu erwarten
seid ihr darauf vorbereitet
wir sind jetzt natürlich mehr darauf
vorbereitet bei schlank und Land sind
niemand von uns sowas auch eine
ansatzweise erleben jetzt haben wir Gott
sei Dank ein Muss Auftritten
Pressetermin und und und und können das
eigentlich ganz locker angehen ich
glaube das ist ein großes Glück dass wir
beim ersten Mal überhaupt nicht wussten
was auf uns zukommt keine Chance hat ein
groß darüber nachzudenken und das ist
dann glücklicherweise ganz gut gegangen
ist und dass wir jetzt nicht so riesig
aufgeregt sein müssen weil wir doch zum
Glück das Leben ein bisschen schon
kennen ganz vergessen über einen zu
reden
und man hat nicht mit ihm gerechnet ähm
wir kennen ihn alle aus Zimmer frei Götz
als Mann habt ihr engagieren können wie
ist das denn passiert wie seid ihr denn
an denen gekommen da waren verschiedene
Gespräch und keinen die sich wirklich
realistisch daran kommen
man hat nicht unter danke
anzurufen
ging allerdings nicht ganz so gut weil
Götze nur über seine Management dann bei
der vermittelt wird das Management ging
nicht dran ist weil etwas schwierig bis
uns dann ein viel über Kontakt Mensch
wir wissen ja wo der wohnt nein
also
sind dann zwei von uns da vorbeigefahren
haben ganz lieb und höflich angefragt
sein Sohn war dann da der wollte Sache
weiterleiten wir haben das Lied rüber
geschickt und das war alles am Vorabend
des Video gedrehts und ja so gegen
Mittag ich schon aufgebaut die ersten
Szenen gedreht wie ich auf einem Rädchen
hin fahre bisschen die Perücke in die
Waschmaschine stecke und waren gerade
dabei die Disco richtig aufzubauen der
sowas Stellung und da kriegt man Anrufe
Götz hier hallo habt ihr schon gehört
finde und ich bin dabei super das ist
dann quasi noch das Qualitätssiegel auf
Diskothek Hammer also ähm ich bin
unglaublich gespannt ob das was wird ich
kann es mir anders nicht vorstellen ja
ähm ich hoffe es auch glaube auch fest
daran wie gesagt ich möchte mir hier
anmaßen die Leute einschätzen zu können
ich kann nur sagen das liegt macht eine
riesige Menge Spaß es wird immer
reichen in der Regel für einen
mindestens kleinen
denke an super vielen Dank